in A Song of Ice and Fire and Game of
Thrones
dragonglass or obsidian is a mysterious
material with special magical properties
relating to White Walkers and dragons
it's used by the children of the forest
and the Nights Watch and may play an
important role in the ending of this
series so let's have a look
obsidian exists in the real world it's a
volcanic glass that forms from cold lava
historically obsidians been highly
valued because as well as being quite
beautiful it can be fractured to form
really sharp edges so for thousands of
years all over the world it's been used
to make tools and weapons like blades
and arrowheads as well as objects of
artistic and religious significance on
Easter Island the moai statues had
obsidian four eyes in anatolia mirrors
were made out of obsidian and in
mesoamerica the aztecs used obsidian
knives in bloodletting rituals and human
sacrifice now obsidian is used to make
surgical scalpels with blades sharper
than steel is considered a magical stone
by various new agey folks and is a high
tier crafting material in Minecraft and
Terraria so in a way we still seem to
value obsidian to this day anyway in
Game of Thrones obsidian has basically
the same physical properties that it has
in the real world it's apparently formed
from volcanic activity though there are
alternative theories its slick and shiny
and usually black though it can be other
colors it's very brittle and can form
razor-sharp edges and it's being used by
ancient peoples for thousands of years
though in Game of Thrones those people
aren't humans the original inhabitants
of Westeros are the Giants and the
children of the forest the Giants
apparently knew of no better tools or
weapons and branches pulled from trees
but the children of the forest had great
art in working obsidian and used it to
make tools and weapons for hunting
eventually human settlers came to
Westeros the first men and later the
Andals who all but wiped out the Giants
and children who now only survived in
small numbers north of the wall but the
humans value obsidian - its traded and
used in ornamentation in sword hilts and
rings and things crow food amber wears a
chunk of dragon glass in his empty eye
socket
so obsidian is around in small amounts
but it's only during the events of A
Song of Ice and Fire that people start
to realize just how important obsidian
is in clash Jon Snow finds a cache of
obsidian weapons wrapped up in a Night's
Watch cloak and buried on the fist of
the first men the cloak hasn't rotted
suggesting that the obsidian was
recently buried so it might have been
Benjen Stark who left it or maybe cold
hands for Bloodraven in the show it's a
bit different gran and Sam find the
cache beneath the stone marked with
ruins of the first man suggesting that
it might have been left by ancient
nights Watchmen whoever buried it Jon
takes some of the obsidian and gives it
to his friends in the watch Sam gets one
of the daggers and discovers its
importance when the others come the
others or White Walkers are strange icy
creatures from beyond the wall have been
killing humans and raising them as
whites basically zombies in an army of
the Dead
apparently intent on killing everything
that lives it may actually be more
complicated than that but either way
it's looking like the Nights Watch will
have to stop them
the whites can be killed with fire or by
chopping them into bits but the others
are really hard to kill they're
apparently invulnerable to most normal
blades and we've never seen them hurt by
fire the only thing to have seen kill a
white Walker at least in the books is
Sam's obsidian dagger when Sam stabs a
walker with obsidian the Walker
dissolves melts away its body smoking
and steaming where it touches the dagger
this stuff is like white Walker
kryptonite it has this fiery magic to it
which is hugely destructive to the icy
White Walkers
so the Nights Watch wants more obsidian
all they have now are the few daggers
and arrowheads and stuff that Jon took
from the fist of the first man and also
some wildlings of obsidian weapons
there's still lots more obsidian at the
fist or at hardhome in the show but with
all these whites and walkers around
it'll be too dangerous to go back for
the cash so as Jeor Mormont says they
need to find dragon class someplace else
luckily for the watch there are at least
four different places they could get
some firstly when Stannis Baratheon
comes to the wall he agrees with the
watch that they need to get more
obsidian to fight the others he says
that on the island of Dragonstone where
he originally ruled
there are tunnels full of obsidian whole
chunks of it boulders and ledges so
Stannis orders his men back on
Dragonstone to start mining this
obsidian the only problem is that in the
next book Dragonstone is besieged and
captured by the forces of King Tommen
and we don't know whether any of Stannis
is obsidian makes it off the island mace
Tyrell says that after its capture no
wealth is found on Dragonstone that
every inch of the island is searched and
not a single gemstone or speck of gold
is found though Kevan Lannister doubts
this so basically it's uncertain but
possible that some of the Obsidian mined
on Dragonstone makes it off the island
and is shipped towards the wall maybe to
arrive in the next book the second way
the watch could get obsidian is from
scar goes scar goes is a big island just
east of the wall and its people the scar
go see are infamous for savagery
cannibalism human sacrifice and
apparently riding unicorns in dance
devil set sail for Skoda's because
apparently Rickon stark is taken there
by OSHA so it looks like ska goes will
be an important location in the next
book and the thing is the skull GoSee
are known to offer obsidian blades in
trade ska goes may be an important
source of obsidian for the watch so with
any luck we'll soon see
Rickon stark riding a unicorn to the
wall with the big stash of dragonglass
to fight the others the third possible
source of obsidian is Valyria Valyria is
where the Targaryen xand that dragons
originally came from it was once the
center of a huge powerful Empire but was
destroyed in a massive mysterious fiery
apocalypse known as the doom of Valyria
we don't really know what caused the
doom but it seems to have been volcanic
and part of the destruction involved
dragonglass
raining down from the sky so presumably
there's still a whole lot of obsidian
lying around in the ruins of Valyria
Valyria is now considered a cursed
dangerous place avoided by just about
everyone but if say Daenerys Targaryen
was brave enough to stop off at our
ancestral homeland on our way to
Westeros she might just be able to pick
up a supply of obsidian imagine her
turning up at the wall when the walkers
come knocking bringing not only
fire-breathing dragons but enough
obsidian to arm every man on the
that would be a perfect way to stop the
others and for Daenerys to prove herself
to the realm she intends to rule this is
just speculation and George Martin has
been kind of ambivalent about whether
will actually see Valyria though it has
been shown in the show so we don't know
it seems maybe not likely but surely
possible that Dany will deliver obsidian
from Valyria the fourth possible source
of obsidian is the children of the
forest we know that they've used
obsidian for thousands of years we know
that the children still exist north of
the wall and we are told that the last
time the others came thousands of years
ago they were stopped with the help of
the children of the forest which seems
to have involved the children providing
the Nights Watch with obsidian this may
also be related to the legendary hero
azor Ahai or the last hero a figure who
apparently led humanity against the
white walkers with a flaming sword
called light bringer some fans
speculated that this magic sword may
have been made of obsidian or some
obsidian alloy because many of the
powers of light bringer can be explained
by the properties of obsidian it kills
white walkers it burns without being
consumed it can emit bright light a tale
of azor Ahai says when he stabbed a
monster with Lightbringer the creature
steamed and smoked and melted just like
a white Walker steams and smokes and
melts when Sam stabs it with obsidian so
there seems to be a connection here
between Azure ahyes magical sword and
obsidian maybe the children of the
forest will help us or a high Forge
another light bringer or maybe light
bringer was actually not one sword but
the many hundreds of obsidian weapons
given to the Nights Watch by the
children which over thousands of years
became the myth of a single hero with a
single magic sword
saving the world so now we don't know
the point here is that the children of
the forest may give the watch obsidian
and this could somehow be related to
this azor Ahai prophecy business and
that makes for really cool ways that the
Nights Watch could get obsidian to fight
the others and to decide the outcome of
what may be the biggest conflict in the
conclusion of the series but there's
still another reason why obsidian is
important glass candles glass candles
are magical artifacts from Valyria tall
twisted chunks of obsidian that can
function as candles they seem to be
closely connected to the power of
magic in the world apparently no one had
succeeded in lighting a glass candle for
many many years until the recent
reawakening of magic with the birth of
new dragons on the return of the White
Walkers in feast we see that Marlin the
mage has succeeded in lighting a glass
candle which symbolizes this magical
reawakening but glass candles aren't
just symbolic they're also very powerful
tools Mullen says that the sorcerers of
Illyria could see across mountain seas
and deserts with glass candles they
could enter a man's dreams and give him
visions and speak to one another half a
world apart we've actually already seen
this magic at work quaithe the
mysterious asha a shadow bender appears
to Daenerys in strange dreams and gives
her cryptic advice apparently using a
glass candle this use of fire magic to
see across long distances and enter
people's dreams contrasts with the magic
of the old gods and the weirwoods
which Bloodraven and brand news to do
the same things to see across long
distances and enter people's dreams the
way Melisandre and mokoro see visions in
their flames may also be related here
because it also seems a similar magic
using fire to see images so all this
gives a sense of order to the magic in
this world anyway we know Marwan and
Quaithe have glass candles and it's
actually possible that they're using
them to communicate and work together
because when Quaithe warns an heiress
about everyone who's coming for her she
leaves out Marwan as well as Quaithe and
Marwan glass candles are owned by the
other masters of the Citadel someone
called Ruth on night Walker in Qarth
and also the Targaryen szávay Mons day
seem to have had some we don't know much
about how these candles are being used
but they're obviously very powerful and
could play a big role in the future of
the series hopefully we'll learn more
about them while Sam is at the Citadel
anyway that is pretty much everything we
know about obsidian it kills White
Walkers
so the Nights Watch will probably need
some and luckily there are a bunch of
interesting ways they can get more there
are also glass candles which we don't
know much about but could also be really
important later on thanks for watching
feel free to like and subscribe if you'd
like to see more and thanks also to the
patrons who support this channel
including Travis cook Carson wilds
Caroline Faye on
monster mug chip Marshall snow and to
vine yard dog who requested this topic
special thanks also to Sean woods who
kindly allowed the use of his video
about making obsidian arrowheads there's
a link in the description if you'd like
to check out his channel so thank you
all again and comment below to let us
know what you'd like to see next
Cheers